[Music]
on this tuesday night
class is in session in the time of covet
19.
the unprecedented back to school jitters
when physical distancing
is not an option the number one thing
that provinces
should be insisting upon is social
distancing
the u.s president unwelcome in wisconsin
we don't have any words for the orange
man
how trump is describing the police
shootings of unarmed black men
and recognizing residential schools it's
important that we learn from our history
both good and bad
acknowledging a shameful chapter of
canada's past
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
with september now upon us families
across this country
are in transition mode as kids head back
to school
the official first day back is different
depending on where you live
but people everywhere are feeling
similar anxiety over how
school will work in the time of covet
19.
in some regions it's been a rocky start
in alberta where many students went back
to class today
one school was forced to remain closed
after a staff member
tested positive public health officials
have warned
there's no way to reduce the risk to
zero but some parents and teachers say
more could be done to limit the spread
of the virus
in tonight's top story jeff semple looks
at the lingering concerns
as class returns students in calgary
returned to the classrooms with their
required masks and cohorts
becoming the latest to join the national
experiment
on safe schooling in a pandemic it's
nice to
maybe get a sense of normalcy going
forward but we'll have to see right
meters
cannot be maintained students will be
required
to wear masks in all shared and common
areas
including hallways and on-school buses i
think from a messaging standpoint
i am confused because obviously physical
distancing spreading people out is one
of the biggest
tools that we have against covet 19. and
yet for many teachers across the country
physical distancing feels like a distant
dream
to have classrooms of 30 35 students
in classrooms that can't physically have
desks far enough apart to even maintain
a one meter distance
is you know concerning to put it mildly
ontario's four major teachers unions are
filing formal complaints with the
province's labor board
citing unsafe working conditions and
demanding smaller classes
the number one thing that uh provinces
should be insisting upon is social
distancing
uh and smaller class sizes as a result
in hiring more teachers wonderful off
you go have a great day of learning
excellent ontario's premier who toured a
school ahead of students returning next
week
insists the unions are playing politics
and his plan is based on science
i'm going to always listen to the docs
in science infectious disease experts
interviewed by global news
are divided on the issue of smaller
classes
some believe the situation is manageable
we have very low
community burden of disease so this
reduces the risk for
everybody in all circumstances and i
think that right now the chance of
getting coveted at school is quite low
in new brunswick with only a few cases
of covid19 the government is
disregarding distancing and relying
instead on student
bubbles within their classroom groupings
students will
be able to interact with other students
and educators without
physical distancing whatever the model
school
is now in session and the debate around
distancing
is no longer theoretical jeff sample
global news toronto
schools around the world are also
reopening this week
that includes europe despite an upward
trend in new infections
in heart at spain kids as young as six
must wear masks but in england
also severely impacted by covet 19 most
students won't be required to wear face
coverings
as redmond shannon reports governments
are watching nervously to see
which back-to-school plans pass and
which ones fail
students and parents listening intently
on a back to school day with more nerves
than normal
this mother says she has a heart
condition and will take her daughter
out of school if there are any positive
cases
even though attendance is mandatory in
france at least for part of the week
this incredible country is getting back
on its feet and
recovering from this crisis in the uk
the government has faced heavy
criticism from teachers for waiting
until last
friday before issuing its pandemic
planning for schools
we've had to have staggered drop-offs in
the morning collections in the afternoon
different play times in different
locations in a late policy u-turn
england will only require masks in
high school corridors in regions with
high infection rates
scotland and northern ireland will
require masks in all high schools
wales is leaving the decision with each
school
a recent study showed kids in england to
be three months behind on their learning
with poorer students worst affected
in spain where the virus was just as
deadly as the uk much stricter rules are
in effect
everything possible has been done says
school director mother marta
masks are mandatory for all spanish kids
over the age of five
everyone has their temperature taken and
desks are
1.5 meters apart
this teacher fears cases will still
surge after schools reopen
sweden however never closed schools and
didn't advise
mask wearing for pupils or staff it does
have an overall death rate
almost as high as spain but a joint
government study said infections among
children have been no higher than in
neighboring finland
where schools were closed although one
swedish school did see a quarter of its
staff
infected and one teacher die of covert
19.
redmond shannon global news london
more than a million students are back in
class in what was once
ground zero of the pandemic after months
of lockdowns and restrictions
wuhan has now reopened all schools and
kindergartens
it's a big step for the city which
suffered the worst covenant outbreak in
china
as part of the new rules students must
wear masks to
and from school and avoid public transit
if possible
india is pressing ahead with its
academic plans despite having one of the
fastest growing caseloads in the world
today more than 2 million students sat
for their college admission exams
the government had faced pressure to
defer the tests but refused
since the start of the pandemic more
than 3.6 million people
in india have tested positive
the privy council office has now hired a
consulting firm to review
allegations of workplace harassment
inside rideau hall
governor general julie payette is
accused of creating a toxic and
unbearable environment for staff
there are reports she belittled and
publicly humiliated employees
reducing some to tears both current and
former staff members will be interviewed
by quintet consulting corporation
on a voluntary basis payette will also
get a meeting with the firm
ndp ethics critic charlie angus says he
hopes the results and any
recommendations will be made public
with action taken if needed
i have met madame payette a number of
times and i have enormous respect for
her
but she represents the canadian people
and has to meet the highest standards
and
these allegations are deeply concerning
payette secretary and long-time friend
assunta de lorenzo is also accused of
abusive treatment
fayette says she takes workplace
harassment issues very seriously and
welcomes an independent review the final
report is due
later this fall the american president
is adding more fuel to the fire in the
wake of the police shooting of jacob
blake that triggered
deadly protests today donald trump
surveyed the damage in kenosha
he chose not to meet blake's family and
instead used his time
to praise police trump was never welcome
in wisconsin
but as jackson proskow reports he went
anyway
the mayor and governor had asked him to
stay home
president donald trump came to kenosha
wisconsin anyway
we're going to work with you we're going
to help you okay we'll help you rebuild
touring the damage from nights of
protest over the police shooting of
jacob blake
meeting with police but not blake's
family all i ask is that
he keep his disrespect his foul language
far away from our family
we need a president that's going to
unite our country and take us in a
different direction
kenosha is still reeling
it's not just only about jake being shot
it exposes inequality
so we cannot just be freed must also be
equal trump has poured gasoline on the
fire
without acknowledging the reason for the
demonstrations do you believe systemic
racism is a problem in this country
well you know you just keep getting back
to the opposite subject we should talk
about the kind of violence that we've
seen
the president has instead likened police
who shoot unarmed black men
to a bad game of golf but they choke
just like
in a golf tournament they miss a three
foot
two months out from election day the
president is stoking fears of
widespread violence to shore up his base
critics accuse him of openly fanning the
flames
when has he condemned anything that's
occurred
on the far right when has he spoken up
about peace and unity when has he done
that
trump claims things will only get worse
under a biden presidency
the chaos has arrived under his own
women in the suburbs have gotten tired
of
his posture on so many issues can he win
them back with the law and order
turn with a pledge to restore law and
order i
frankly doubt it for trump the violent
protests are a distraction from the
other issues gripping everyday american
life
the pandemic record unemployment and the
most closely watched election
in a generation
and for the first time today trump
offered condolences to jacob blake and
his family saying he feels
terrible for anyone who goes through a
thing like that after being asked by
reporters
he also offered up a million dollars in
funding for kenosha's police force
keep in mind the context here wisconsin
is a swing state it helped put trump
over the top in 2016
and robin it will be vital to securing
his re-election in 2020.
jackson frost gun washington thanks
jackson to the digital battle in
australia now
facebook is threatening to block users
in that country from sharing local
and international news stories it's in
response to a proposed code by
australia's competition watchdog
it wants companies like facebook and
google to pay a fair price to local news
organizations for displaying their
content
the australian government is trying to
curb the power of these platforms and to
offset
advertising revenue losses a
twelve-year-old boy
gets busted coming up the joyride that
sent him straight to police
plus creative campaigning how to vie for
votes with the coronavirus around
and north korea's new mandate kim
jong-un's orders to his soldiers
at the border
a 12 year old is in big trouble today
after he was caught going on a joyride
in toronto
early this morning police responded to
calls of an suv driving erratically on a
major highway
nearly hitting other vehicles officers
eventually caught up and found a boy
clearly way too young to be behind the
wheel the boy's father says he was
asleep at the time
unaware where his son was until police
showed up
at his front door this boy
has been a good well-behaved boy
he's obedient he's mild-mannered he
talks respectfully to everybody
has he ever done anything like this no
nothing like this at all
the father was then brought to the scene
to pick up his son luckily there were no
injuries or damage to the vehicle
no word on any charges governments
across canada are keeping a close eye on
new brunswick where the first provincial
election campaign during the pandemic
has crossed
the halfway mark the usual candidate
meet and greece are much more
challenging because of the risk of covet
19.
and as ross lord reports for one
politician who got into the race after
tragedy making a personal connection
with voters means taking extra
precautions
in canada's first pandemic election
candidates in new brunswick are stepping
tentatively
many from the opposition liberals like
stephen burns
are still going door to door i sanitize
my hands
go to the door i will use my pen
to hit the doorbell then i back
up 10 feet and if someone comes to the
door i just
ask them first of all whether they're
okay with me being here
and having a conversation by contrast
the governing progressive conservatives
are staying away
premier blaine higgs hopes high approval
ratings from stifling covet 19
will turn his thin minority government
into a strong majority
higgs candidates are relying on phone
calls and social media
instead of face-to-face contact i think
they really appreciate the fact that
we're not going up to their door we're
not even putting brochures and mailboxes
my brochures are going to be arriving in
the mail this week
so we're being very cautious you can't
be too careful
as a first-timer burns says traditional
campaigning gives him
an edge i've only had a couple people
out of those thousand that had any
concern and once i explained to them
you know how it works they were more
than fine to uh to talk to me
for him awkward conversations are
nothing new his wife sarah a fredericton
police officer
was one of four people killed by a
gunman two years ago
leaving him as a single parent to their
three boys burns is campaigning on a
call for better
mental health services for youth and
that
obviously stems from the things that i
went through with my kids and and
the the death of my wife wilson says the
pcs have already made mental health a
priority
number one announcement so top priority
so we have to agree completely
as they disagree on how to deliver their
messages
in this campaign unlike any other ross
lord
global news still ahead how french
satire
is striking back as a tragedy is put on
trial
[Music]
developments tonight in the case of the
man who inspired the hollywood film
hotel rwanda tonight paul
russo-savagina's family accuses rwanda's
government of kidnapping the 66 year old
on made-up charges rusa sabagena an
outspoken critic of rwanda's government
is now being held in rwanda's capital he
had traveled to dubai where he was
arrested on terror charges
rwanda's president holds close ties with
the united arab emirates
and has been accused of hunting down
critics overseas
in 1996 russo sabagena fled rwanda and
sought political asylum in belgium
in 2016 he announced a political
campaign against rwanda's government
which he labeled a dictatorship the
french satirical newspaper
charlie hebdo is republishing
controversial cartoons of the prophet
muhammad
as the trial for the deadly terror
attack on its paris office begins
the publication hasn't reprinted the
images since the aftermath
of the january 2015 attack which killed
several cartoonists the editors say we
have always refused to do so
not because it is prohibited the law
allows us to do so
but because there was a need for a good
reason to do it
a reason which has meaning and which
brings something to the debate
14 people are accused of being
accomplices in the shooting sprees
at the charlie hebdo offices and at a
kosher supermarket two days later
a total of 17 people died all three
gunmen involved were killed in shootouts
with police
the president of the philippines is
publicly ordering the country's top
customs official to shoot and kill
drug smugglers it's one of rodrigo
duterte's most overt threats yet
under his anti-drug crackdown he says he
fears narcotics are flowing into the
philippines through its ports
where corruption is deeply rooted more
than
5 700 mostly poor drug suspects
have been killed during duterte's
four-year anti-drug campaign
the focal point of his presidency
and north korea appears to be taking a
heavy-handed approach to cracking down
on the spread of covet-19.
leader kim jong-un has reportedly
ordered police and soldiers to shoot
anyone who gets within one kilometer of
the chinese border
the government is sending ammunition to
help officials carry out the new policy
which will be in effect until the
pandemic ends north korea claims to be
the only virus free country
in the world up next recognizing
canada's residential schools and their
place
in history
you're watching global national
the residential school system is a dark
chapter in canadian history
tens of thousands of indigenous metis
and inuit children
were forced to attend the government-run
institutions nearly 3 000 children are
known to have died
while at the schools it's likely many
other deaths were not documented
the abuse many experienced has affected
generations of families
today the federal government recognized
the system as a defining event that's
not to be forgotten
and as abigail beeman reports two former
schools
will now be national historic sites
that's where i slept
when he goes inside the former portage
la prairie manitoba residential school
now
ernie daniels smells chlorine five six
years old
all dragged up the stairs that way and
thrown into a
bathtub full of chlorine he grew up to
become
chief then successfully fought to
reclaim the building and surrounding
land
daniels calls the national historic site
designation
vindication we had a long road
winding road to this day former schools
in portage la prairie and schubernacher
nova scotia are now national historic
sites and the entire residential school
system is being declared historically
significant
as we recall the phrase to kill
the indian within the child for canada
to move forward and move forward in an
inclusive way and particularly with
indigenous peoples on a path to
reconciliation
it's important that we recognize our
history that we learn from our history
both good and bad
learn more about what it is that's
happened learn
more about
why we use terms like cultural genocide
when we're talking about this sit with
that concept for a bit
be uncomfortable those working on
reconciliation say the announcement is
just the beginning and it's not just
about more designations
the government has been criticized for
being slow to act on the 94 calls to
action the truth and reconciliation
commission made in 2015
commemoration is part of that there are
many many
calls to action that have yet to be
implemented we still have to find
all of the kids that remain in unmarked
burial sites across the country
in portage lorraine daniels has been
working on opening a national museum
inside the old school
slowed by covet 19 and a lack of funding
it is going to be a place
where they're hurt because of the
residential school era
and will now be a place of healing she
says survivors are often asked to
forgive
but all canadians should never forget
this part of history
abigail beeman global news ottawa
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with the start of a
poignant return
two of canada's snowbirds finally took
off from kamloops today over three
months after they lost one of their own
to tragedy
they're making their way home to their
base in moose jaw saskatchewan
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back here tomorrow and i'll see
you this weekend
have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you